it takes two to make an accident
there are only the pursued the pursuing
the busy and the tired
it is not life that's complicated it's
the struggle to guide and control life
never confuse activity with action
great books write themselves only bad
books have to be written
there are all kinds of love in this
world but never the same love twice
reserving judgments as a matter of
infinite hope
genius is the ability to put into effect
what is on your mind
experience is the name so many people
give to their mistakes
the world only exists in your eyes you
can make it as big or as small as you
want
there's no substitute for will
sometimes you have to fake will when you
don't feel it at all
[Music]
no grand idea was ever born in a
conference but a lot of foolish ideas
have died there
i don't want to repeat my innocence i
want the pleasure of losing it again
men get to be a mixture of the charming
mannerisms of the women they have known
no amount of fire or freshness can
challenge what a man will store up in
his ghostly heart
a great social success is a pretty girl
who plays her cards as carefully as if
she were playing
let us learn to show our friendship for
a man when he is alive and not after he
is dead
before you criticize others remember
they may not have had the same
opportunities in life as you have had
it is not merely enough to have the
ability to be persistent you must also
have the ability to start over
[Music]
i never blame failure there are too many
complicated situations in life but i am
absolutely merciless toward lack of
effort
you don't write because you want to say
something you write because you have
something to say
life is a comedy for those who think in
a tragedy for those who feel
show me a hero and i will write you a
tragedy
i'm a slave to my emotions to my likes
to my hatred of boredom to most of my
desires
intelligence is measured by a person's
ability to see validity within both
sides of contradicting arguments
it was only a sunny smile and little it
cost in the giving but like morning
light it scattered the night and made
the day worth living
[Music]
the ability to hold two competing
thoughts in one's mind and still be able
to function is the mark of a superior
mind
i was within and without simultaneously
enchanted and repelled by the
inexhaustible variety of life
to be kind is more important than to be
right many times what people need is not
a brilliant mind that speaks but a
special heart that listens
my idea is always to reach my generation
the wise writer writes for the youth of
his own generation the critics of the
next and the schoolmasters of ever
afterward
courage to me means plowing through that
dull grey mist that comes down on life
not only overriding people and
circumstances but overriding the
bleakness of living
no amount of fire or freshness can
challenge what a man will store up in
his ghostly heart
the greatest profound pain is cased by
and is the result of our own illusions
fantasies and dreams
you see i usually find myself among
strangers because i drift here and
they're trying to forget the sad things
that happened to me
for what it's worth it's never too late
to be whoever you want to be
i hope you live a life you're proud of
and if you find that you're not i hope
you have the strength to start
when a woman tests your confidence and
you don't crumble it confirms to her
that you are worthy of being in the
masculine position
that is part of the beauty of all
literature you discover that your
longings are universal longings that
you're not lonely and isolated from
anyone
you belong
either you think or else others have to
think for you and take power from you
pervert and discipline your natural
tastes civilize and sterilize you
it took him a moment to respond to the
unguarded sweetness of her smile her
body calculated to a millimeter to
suggest a bud yet guarantee a flower
the idea that to make a man work you've
got to hold gold in front of his eyes as
a growth not an axiom
we've done that for so long that we've
forgotten there's any other way